[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comme vous voyez je suis une personne en
fauteuil comme on dit UNE personne en
situation de handicap
mais ça a du bon je peux prendre mes
lunettes et mes fiches au cas où
comme vous l'imaginez je vais vous
parler d'un handicap mais pas de cet
indicateur mais plutôt de la situation
handicapante vous savez celle où l'on se
sent démunie ou parfois même tout nous
semble fichus
ou parfois même tout nous sommes fichu
ça commence fort
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci mais avant laissez-moi vous parler
d'un temps où tout était parfait pour
moi j'ai 14 ans je cours je saute je
pratique la gymnastique depuis 8 ans je
suis passionné très heureuse et mes huit
années de bonheur et d'efforts bien
d'être couronnés par une sélection
nationale
c'est moi
nous sommes à 15 jours des championnats
de France on t'a demandé répétition
intensif et c'est l'accident je vais
chuter au barrage symétrique je devais
réaliser comme un salto entre les bars
et au préalable rattraper la barre
supérieure et parfois il m'arrivait de
la rattraper du bout des doigts je
mettais un coup de rein pour la
reprendre pleine de main mais ce jour-là
mon coup de reine va pas suffire ma
rotation a déjà débuté et je vais chuter
sur le bas du dos
la douleur est atroce puis tout va très
vite pompier hôpital examen radio bloc
opératoire
le lendemain je me réveille dans une
chambre d'hôpital entouré de ma famille
là le médecin m'explique que mon
intervention a duré 12 heures que je ne
fracture et luxation de la colonne
vertébrale que la luxation a entraîné un
pincement de la moelle épinière et qu'au
niveau de ce pincement les influx
nerveux ne descendent plus vers mes
jambes
et on me dit qu'il va falloir du temps
de mon côté je suis sûr de participer 15
jours après au championnat de France
au lieu de ça 15 jours après direction
le centre de rééducation
point positif je vais enfin commencer ma
rééducation objectif remarcher
je fais la connaissance de Sylvie
matinée jeunes tonic ça match là le
médecin m'explique que je dois rester
allongé le temps que ma colonne
vertébrale cicatrice
de moi se sont écoulés
Harry enfin le jour où je vais pouvoir
me rasoir on m'a fabriqué un beau corset
Sylvie le médecin sont là pour m'aider à
m'asseoir et à me relever au bord du lit
il m'aide il m'aide il m'a dit m'aide ça
y est je suis assise tout va bien aucune
douleur yes première étape de franchie
première victoire
le lendemain me présente mon fauteuil
roulant
pour moi une libération la liberté de
pouvoir sortir de ma chambre de pouvoir
aller manger à table avec mes compagnons
de galère de pouvoir aller dehors alors
je continue je garde le cap objectif
remarcher
les journées de rééducation s'enchaînent
je travaille dur je rappe tous les
gestes de la vie quotidienne mais malgré
mes efforts si moi ce sont écoulés
malgré tous mes efforts au niveau de ma
moelle épinière et de mes jambes
toujours aucune amélioration
alors je prends conscience petit à petit
de la gravité de ma blessure
je suis toujours assise et le plus
redoutable pour moi ça va être quand je
me retrouve seul face à moi-même dans ma
chambre le soir où je vais passer par
toutes ces étapes du déni de la colère
et me poser beaucoup de questions
pourquoi moi
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait pour mériter ça
comment je vais supporter ça qu'est-ce
que je vais devenir
tout me manque les copains la gym le
collège
je ne me supporte plus je déverse ma
colère sur mon entourage qui continue
malgré tout à venir me voir chaque jour
et à me porter
9 mois se sont écoulés et toujours
aucune amélioration
je comprends je comprends que je vais
probablement plus remarcher
mes pensées sont noires plus aucune
certitude sur mes jeunes filles sur ma
vie de femme sur ma vie professionnelle
ma rééducation est bientôt terminée je
vais bientôt rentrer à la maison et cet
après-midi cet après-midi là mais ma
mère nous marchons dans les couloirs du
centre de centre de rééducation moi avec
mes cannes elle à côté
je vais lui dire la phrase la plus
douloureuse que j'ai jamais dites non
pas par culpabilité ni par honte mais
parce que la dire ça va être me l'avouer
à moi-même
tu sais
je crois que je ne remarcherai plus
ce à quoi elle va me répondre avec un
sourire rassurant
mais tu sais ma fille même à 6 on peut
en faire des choses
waouh
elle a rien compris mais qu'est-ce
qu'elle me dit là
moi qui voyait là devant moi un mur un
surmontable infranchissable non
seulement elle est en train de me
confirmer que je vais rester cloué sur
ce fauteuil mais en plus on le tomber en
sanglot elle me dit que tout n'est pas
foutu
alors croyez-moi grâce à ses mots en un
dixième de seconde dans mon esprit va
réapparaître une minuscule lumière mais
surtout elle nouvelle espoir
ben oui tu as raison je vais
probablement rester cloué sur ce
fauteuil mais peut-être que même assise
on peut faire des choses
alors je ne suis pas en train de vous
dire que ça va être facile instantané
que je pas de voir encore cheminée
durant de longs mois pour faire le deuil
de ce que j'étais de ce que j'aurais pu
être de certaines mes amis de mes
passions
mais je sais désormais que je dois
continuer à 6
alors sportif dans l'âme très vite j'ai
envie de reprendre une activité mais
laquelle choisir pourquoi pas le tennis
moi à ce moment là j'ai qu'une envie
c'est de m'amuser et je me dis allez
taper la balle sur un cours au soleil à
mes frères mes potes super
alors au début ben je vais pas du tout
m'amuser repartir de zéro tour et
apprendre mais la Vienne parle je
persiste entraînement régulier
coup droit replacement
coup droit replacement revers vous les
services quelques gammes et plusieurs
années plus tard me voilà reparti cette
fois-ci elles m'ont fauteuil j'enchais
les tournois bon j'enchaîne aussi au
début pas mal de défaites mais je
persiste je passe des Caps je commence à
gagner je gagne de plus en plus
jusqu'à me laisser au niveau national
j'intègre le coup France stage circuit
international et encore plusieurs années
plus tard et plusieurs victoires plus
tard je pars bien à me sélectionner pour
les Jeux paralympiques de Barcelone 1992
et attentat 96 et je remporterai deux
médailles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
extraordinaire des souvenirs
inoubliables le Graal pour un sportif
waouh et quelle satisfaction
imaginez-vous
et vous savez quoi
je ne rêve plus de Nadia comme un
je suis devenu une joueuse de tennis
certes assise mais je m'entraîne tous
les jours et désormais quand je rentre
sur un cours c'est dans l'intention de
gagner yes
et après ces deux belles médailles et 10
années de haut niveau et bien je veux
travailler en parallèle j'ai poursuivi
mes études j'ai obtenu un Master en
Management du Sport et mon rêve c'est de
travailler au sein d'un gros comité
d'entreprise
donc j'avoue mon CV et sur mon CV bien
sûr apparaît toute cette expérience
numéro une Française quatre mondiales
tous les troncs internationaux les
coupes du monde les Jeux paralympiques
mes médailles j'ai aussi été président
d'une association de tennis handisport
pendant 8 ans avec l'organisation des
tournois international annuel
donc tout ça paraît et j'envoie mon CV
et j'obtiens 6 entretiens
et là
au bout de 5 minutes pour les plus
pressés et un peu plus pour les autres
tous me dire
mademoiselle nous ne sommes pas prêts à
accueillir une personne comme vous
waouh me voilà nouveau devant les murs
waouh
ça va être violent
moi qui est arrivé des jeux moi qui vais
poursuivre études mais je pensais
poursuivre ma carrière professionnelle
comme tout un chacun
alors oui on va me refuser mais j'ai
appris à trouver des solutions alors je
vais réfléchir et là il faut que je
trouve une solution je vais réfléchir
longuement et puis je me dis puisque ce
fauteuil est une barrière puisqu'il fait
si peur je vais décider de changer mon
fusil d'épaule et d'aller vers les
personnes qui me connaissaient avant mon
accident et qui aurait peut-être moins
peur de cette situation
et ça va être le cas avec le maire d'une
commune qui me connaissait valide et bon
élève puisque c'était le maire puisque
pardon c'était le principal adjoint du
collège où j'étais scolarisé
ma candidature va être retenue je
passais les entretiens puis toutes les
étapes du recrutement et je vais piloter
durant 16 ans le service des sports de
la ville yes merci
[Musique]
et Baby de femme dans tout ça
avec mon homme parce que
nous voulions être parents mais nous
nous sommes posés beaucoup de questions
d'autant plus que lui aussi membre de
l'équipe de France membre de l'équipe de
France de tennis fauteuil élu aussi en
fauteuil roulant l'amour
le porter les levé le regard des autres
le rendre heureux est-ce que ça va être
possible
alors aujourd'hui je peux vous le dire
le porter
9 mois extraordinaire
le maître au monde nous le savions
césarienne obligatoire ok tout le monde
va bien c'est le principal
pour ce qui est de le rendre heureux et
du regard des autres et bien nous avons
géré nous gérons comme tous parents
mais pour certaines activités qui nous
te les particulièrement à cœur
pourquoi pas déléguer en résumé pour
jouer au tennis et aux échecs parce que
son papa est aussi passionné de chèque
ce sera avec papa et maman et pour aller
s'éclater sur le sable fin à la plage ce
sera avec Mamie et les cousins
aujourd'hui
et c'est le plus beau bien sûr
[Applaudissements]
alors vous l'avez compris au cours de ma
vie j'ai dû à plusieurs reprises changer
de regard sur du site sur des situations
handicapantes pour trouver des solutions
et cela m'a ouvert de nouvelles
perspectives
et vous
est-ce que vous aussi
vous rencontrez des situations où vous
sentez démunies ou peut-être même un mur
se dresse là devant vous qui vous paraît
insurmontable
alors maintenant vous le savez
en changeant de regard ou en abordant la
situation sous un autre angle peut-être
bien de droite à vous de nouvelles
opportunités
en quelque sorte changer de regard pour
un autre départ ça ferait pas penser un
voyage ça c'est Proust qui disait le
seul unique le vrai voyage c'est de
changer de regard
et je termine avec mes belles lunettes
roses
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour
[Applaudissements]